نستضيف جميله ميسون عزام التي تطل
بمايكروفون صباح العربيه حتى تجيبنا على
السؤال ماذا حصل في المساواه في المنطقه
صباح الخير يا ميسون منورتينا من بيروت
صباح الفل راويه صباح الخير عادل شكرا
جزيلا للاستضافه بصباح العربيه مجددا
متناقضتين فيما يتعلق بالمساواه معلومتين
متناقضتين
الامم المتحده تحديدا في المنتدى
فعلا في فجوه خلال المنتدى ما بين الرجل
والمراه ولكن لصالح المراه لانه اذا
الجلسه الاولى كان هناك اربع نساء مقابل
رجل واحد القاعه مليئه بالنساء اكثر من
الرجال فهون في هذا الجانب مما يعني ان
هناك
ولكن بالمقابل هذا هذا عكس كليا ما هو
موجود على الورق والتقرير الذي الذي يصدر
من هذا المؤتمر نتحدث عن انه المنطقه
العربيه بازمه هذه الازمه وصفت بانها
الازمه المزمنه الازمه المزمنه ليس فقط
بهذا الاطار ولكنها ايضا متكامله يعني
لاول مره المنطقه العربيه كامله تقدر تخرج
بشغله ما فيها دفوق اللي هي الازمه فيما
يتعلق بالفجوه ما بين الرجل والمراه
متكامله المعالم يعني شو اللي بدك مشاكل
شو اللي بدك ازمات تؤدي الى عدم المساواه
موجوده
نتحدث عن الامن الغذائي سوري في كل
المجالات نتحدث عن عدم مساواه يعني المراه
ترزع خلف يعني بخطوات خلفيه
بكل المجالات في مقارنه بالرجل
بكل المجالات في المنطقه العربيه وان كانت
تختلف ولكن اذا اخذنا صوره ايجابيه وحده
فيما يتعلق باحسن دوله
مساواه بين الرجل والمراه فهي تشكل رقم 68
على مستوى مؤشر العالم وبالمقابل هناك
تحسن ولكن تحسن بطيء ببعض الدول العربيه
بطيء لدرجه المشي كالحفان نتحدث عن انه
بدنا 164 سنه لحتى نقدر نوصل لمرحله الحد
من هذه الفجوه الموجوده ما بين الرجل
والمراه طبعا الصوره وتوقعات الناس
والتصورات الناس ايضا سايب سيئه فيما
يتعلق بالسنوات الخمسه القادم نتحدث عن
انه 69% من من تم استطلاع ارائهم في
التقرير الصادر عن هذا المنتدى بقولوا انه
لا توقعات بتحسن خلال الخمس سنوات القادمه
فيما يتعلق بالفجوه ما بين الرجل والمراه
للاسف يجب التحرك سريعا البعض يقول بانه
هناك سياسات وسياسات جيده جدا ولكنها
موجوده بالادراج يجب اخراجها من الادراج
لتطبيقها على الارض البعض يقول انه لا
السيستم كله يجب تغييره وبالتالي نتوقع
الاحسن نتمنى اكيد بقى ميسون ربما احنا
نمزح بالفروقات بين الرجل والمراه ولكن
بالتاكيد هناك من الدول العربيه من تسعى
دائما الى تمكين المراه وسد هذه الفجوه
يبقى ربما في سلم من رواتب ربما في بعض
التشريعات والقوانين نتمنى دائما هذا
التقدم شكرا جزيلا ميسون عزام
لحضورك وطلتك الصباحيه قولي عندك 30 ثانيه
راح اقمعك 31 ثانيه
بس قبل ان ننهي
طيب خلاص عندك 30 ثانيه بسرعه
بالنسبه للمراه بالنسبه للدخل على الاقل
للمراه تاخذ حوالي اقل من الربع فيما
يتعلق بالرجل ودخل هذا الرجل وبالمقابل
المشكله الاكبر انه قضيه عدم المساواه
لنصل الى الجنسين هي متراكمه يعني اكثر من
موضوع ومنها موضوع الامن الغذائي كمان
يوصل للمراه اذا كانت مزارعه اذا كانت ام
او غيره يعني الحقيقه ميسون شكرا جزيلا لك
للاسف يعني انا ساعدت باول خبر وكثير قلقت
بعد ما خبرتينا تفاصيل 164 سنه لنغلق هذه
الفجوه ما بين النساء والرجال في العالم
العربي والله يعني الواحد كان يامل وكان
متوقع انه هو خاطي خطوات يعني اكثر
الدراسه التي
نساء المال يعيشن اكثر شكرا يا ميسون وان
شاء الله شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
ومدير
الاخبار الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات